welcome back so today I thought I'd
address all of you guitarists who might
be intimidated by the concept of reading
notes on the guitar you know it's easy
to think there are six strings and each
string has like 19 frets and so I don't
know six times 19 how many notes is that
it sounds like a lot I'm never going to
memorize all those I'll just stick to
tab so today I thought I'd teach you an
easy way to find any note on the guitar
I call this demystifying the fret board
[Music]
if you're at all like me when I was
learning guitar you might know some
notes around the first few frets but
then everything above the fifth fret is
kind of like a mystery this is no man's
land up here and you just say well I'll
just I'll just stick to my chords and
you know maybe playing tab but there's a
quick and easy way of memorizing the
entire fretboard in minutes in in gamer
lingo you might call it a cheat code
let's start by asking the question how
many notes are there in the first place
the answer is kind of surprising just
twelve let's name them a a sharp B C C
sharp D d sharp e f f-sharp G g-sharp
that's it after G sharp we go back to a
and it just keeps going over and over
and over again but hold on that's it
twelve notes and we have the entire
history of western music from Bach with
his Prelude in G major for cello all the
way to Adele's someone like you the same
12 notes just in a different order
that's worth taking a moment to sort of
let that fact sink in
[Music]
so to be clear the musical alphabet is
just a 2 G and then every note gets a
sharp
except for B and E if you want an easy
way to remember that think about
Shakespearean phrase to be or not to be
b b:e those are the notes that are the
exceptions ok so now let's apply this on
the guitar so every fret on the guitar
is a half step apart and coincidentally
every note that we talked about under
the twelfth possible notes are also a
half step apart so if we pick the fifth
string for example hey this would be the
first fret is a sharp C right because
there's no B sure there's no sharp
f-sharp G g-sharp and after we get
through the 12 notes we repeat so we go
back to hey notice we started on a hey
and we end on a that means we've gone
one octave the twelfth fret is where the
octave is in fact that's also why the
harmonic works on that end if you want
you can just keep going from the octave
so that was a a chart B C sharp C sharp
E and then I run out of frets but now we
can do this on any string we just
started a different note so for example
if I go to the B string the second
string this would be B C C sharp D d
sharp F F sharp G etc to take it back to
the octave be a good test to see if you
did it right was if you ended up at the
twelfth fret it has to be the same note
as the open string and if you need a
review on your string names super easy
Eddie ate dynamite good bye and
so e ad GBE Eddie ate dynamite good bye
Eddie
okay time for a quiz so I'm gonna name a
note and a string and you have to find
it so if you want to pause the video and
grab your guitar now this would be a
good moment to give you a test for
example find an f-sharp on the fourth
string d
[Music]
you should have found this note fourth
fret on the fourth string is f-sharp
let's try another one d sharp on the
first string e if you count it all the
way up I feel for you eventually you
would have got to the 11th fret that's d
sharp easier than that would have been
too no oh wait
he is the octave and D sharpest one
before E so you need to quiz yourself at
home what if you quizzed yourself for
five minutes a day think how fast you
would get at this and you don't even
need a guitar for this you can be at the
doctor's office or waiting for the bus
and in your head you can go okay
second string I'm going to find a D
sharp that's on the fourth fret and you
can just keep doing this the more you do
it the faster you'll get it memorizing
all of the notes on the guitar and
lastly depending on the key you're in
you might have to use flats instead of
sharps so to be clear a sharp raises a
note by a half-step a flat lowers a note
by a half step and remember a half-step
is one fret on the guitar so let's say I
went to the a string and I said we mean
a sharp maybe the first for now play a B
that's the second fret okay now play it
B flat flat lowers a note by a half step
the wait a minute that was a sharp so
turns out a sharp and b-flat are
technically the same note the music
lingo term for that is n harmonic and
harmonic is when you have the same note
that could be spelled in two different
ways so now if we want we could restate
the twelve possible notes but using the
N harmonic flats a b-flat B C D flat D
e-flat e f g flat G a flat and that's
the same thing we did before by now
using flats instead of sharps
okay so we've officially done it we have
demystify the fret board and now you are
capable of finding any note along the
frets given it enough time now we need
to do is spend a couple minutes a day
just quiz yourself you can do it with a
guitar or without give it some time and
you're gonna get so good at this so
thanks for watching guys if you haven't
already please do subscribe so you can
get notified when I release the next
guitar tip or a video on my introducing
series see ya
you
[Music]